[Music]
zendaya is giving fans a behind the
scenes look at a song she co-wrote for
the euphoria season 2 finale i don't
know if this feeling will last forever
but i am trying the actress reveals on
her instagram story that she wrote a
couple songs with euphoria composer
labyrinth for the last episode writing i
hope you all like them z then posted
this video of the two recording the
track titled i'm tired
[Music]
the song plays during the final scene of
the season two finale and during the
credits
[Music]
the doom star also shares this photo
with labyrinth just weeks ago on
february 6th re-writing the song rushing
to get it done before their deadline
it's crazy the latest episode of
euphoria caps off a roller coaster
season of emotion as fans followed
zendaya's character rue after relapsing
on drugs it's no future
in addiction
[Music]
how you doing
when'd you relapse
ultimately rue gets clean which senaday
had teased to et last month do you think
there is a sober future for real um
i would like to think so
and despite how dark things got for rue
the season ended on a hopeful note i
stayed clean to the rest of the school
year
i wish i could say that was a decision i
made
in some ways it was just easier i'm
definitely proud of of the work we've
all done and i'm proud of
you know
how far all these characters have come
and now zendaya is celebrating the end
of a successful season posting this
photo on set with co-stars maud apatow
and angus cloud explaining in the
caption it's been a long but beautiful
road last euphoria a day for a while we
hope you enjoy it you know there's a lot
of emotions that are attached to this i
think because this this
show unlike anything else so personal we
uh feel very emotionally invested in in
them and in the project in general i
think that's not just for us but that's
we have an entire crew of people who
dedicate every single day to
to making
hopefully a beautiful piece of art that
resonates with people zee also shared a
peek at the making of lexi's play
posting these images and a bts look at
the moment when maddie chased cassie
through the halls
[Applause]
and good news we're getting even more
euphoria hbo renewed the series for a
season three although it's unclear when
filming will resume one thing's for sure
though zendaya knows aru has a lot more
story to tell
this can't be
the end of her story
because it's just there has to be some
hope
at the end of this some light at the end
of the tunnel you know
i think beautiful at the end of all this
pain and i think that that's what we
really need i think this world world
needs is a little bit of hope in a lot
of ways you know so um
if you can hold on to that if you can
you know bear with her if you can love
her through those those painful moments
and still root for her maybe there's
some hope at the end
[Music]
you